monday edition of pft ot the
place where we spend time talking about
either things we didn't get to or things
we'd like to talk about in more detail
and a thought occurred to me back in the
first segment of our show today chris as
it relates to the jamal adams trade from
the jets the seahawks
that i really wanted to delve into but i
knew we didn't have the time to do it i
wanted to have a little more time to
think about it i oversold it potentially
but now we find out whether or not it is
i'm really excited are you ready i mean
it's the longest damn tease in the
history of tv here so let's go
here we go
we saw the seahawks after the 2017
season pivot away from
that
defensive focus
and begin to build the team around
russell wilson after the 2018 season
russell wilson became the highest paid
player in league history with the
four-year extension new money average of
35 million per year there still is
a lingering sense
that russell wilson at some point
may not be a seahawk i know seahawks
fans don't want to hear that right now
but there is a lingering sense of
frustration as to how he's used you know
you're paying him all that money do you
really let him throw as much as you
should when we did the top 40
quarterback countdown we had the
highlight package of russell wilson it
was obvious how great he is and because
there isn't that
that hair on fire element that a patrick
mahomes has it's not as exciting it's
not as obvious it's not as stunning when
russell wilson goes about doing what he
does so here's my point
you mentioned and i think a lot of
people are coming to this conclusion
that
the future for the seahawks
immediate and long-term is jamal adams
as the center of the defense and russell
wilson is the center of the offense
i look at this and i say
maybe they've decided
to begin
to swing the pendulum back the other way
toward the defense and maybe
at some point in the next couple of
years
there will be a russell wilson trade
that loads up the cannon with draft
picks that lets the seahawks reset that
lets them go find a third round
quarterback who can become one of the
better quarterbacks in the game because
they don't want to pay russell wilson
what he's going to want
the next time a contract comes due now
that patrick mahomes is at 45 million
per year on average in new money could
it be that this relationship is destined
to fall apart could it be that russell
wilson at some level wants it to fall
apart and could it be that this isn't
the jamal and russell show long term
that this jamal adams trade is the first
shot
in a roman candle that results in
russell wilson not being with the
seattle seahawks what do you think about
that well
like i i think
it's not crazy it's a little crazy it's
not totally like you know totally crazy
it's the nicest thing you've ever said
yes well i mean listen i i know what
you're saying here i mean first off
we've seen this team as has the ability
to
build the team with the rookie
quarterback and build a special defense
and have all the other pieces around it
to where you go okay yeah it'd be nice
to have a great quarterback but our
team's so good we don't need to be great
at quarterback or pay him that money and
you're right i mean i don't think pete
carroll and john schneider are afraid to
do that now
you know does this make that you're
right maybe one step closer if we get
down the road here what is it two or
three years from now where maybe they
can get outside of russell's contract to
two years right so
you know maybe that this gives them a
little flexibility to go okay well we
got a guy that we feel like can be the
staple of our defense for probably the
next six or seven years and be a star
right and yeah maybe ride with that see
how things go here in a few years but if
they feel like okay we just can't quite
get over the hump to be the team we
quite need to be to get in the final
four of the super bowl and then you're
right with all the russell wilson
speculation
i think they're a team
like the patriots and maybe a few others
that wouldn't be afraid to make those
type of decisions that's where i'll
certainly back you or make that type of
decision and get rid of or or part ways
with a you know
a special special player like russell
wilson but i think what you're doing
here too is all you get you know now
that i'm starting to think about it and
hear your theory you're almost getting a
little bit of both getting a little
insurance on the back end but also going
okay hey dk metcalf philip dorsett you
know
tyler lockett greg olson whoa we got
some offensive pieces here too and we
helped out the defense just enough here
to where we can legitimately win the
super bowl with russell wilson right now
even though it might not be built the
way we as in john schneider and pete
carroll would love it to be built so i
mean i don't think it's a crazy theory i
think it gives them a little leeway now
actually with the jamal adams to kind of
play both sides of this conversation
and it definitely requires russell
wilson to stay with the seahawks two
more years that salary cap that's
expected to be at 175 million
in 2021 would make it even harder to
move on from his contract it would be a
dead cap number of 39 million i believe
if they if they traded him next year so
uh or at a minimum 32 million it's too
much to take yeah it's too much to move
on it's actually 39 million if they
trade him next year that's not good uh
especially at a 175 million dollar
salary capital he's there two more years
the question arises i think 2022. and by
then they'll know see this is perfect
they have jamal adams under contract for
two more years maybe this isn't this
isn't
the pendulum swinging this is the the
fork in the road
two years out
what are you going to do in the next two
years and if they give jamal adams like
a gigantic contract if they give him
close to 20 million a year between now
and the completion of the 2021 season or
at the latest in the early 2022 off
season that's when you have to ask is
the next move a move on from russell
wilson yeah i just think that we
shouldn't assume and this is my point we
shouldn't assume this is jamal adams
russell wilson five six seven eight
years together in seattle as the two
centerpieces of the team yeah no
seattle's like new england they they'll
do this they'll do what they've got to
do
it's going back the other way to the
defense right because they won super
bowls with a great def well a super bowl
should have been one second one yeah but
they won a super bowl with a great
defense the last two years what have
they gotten
with this approach where russell wilson
is the centerpiece of the team yeah they
lost in the wild card round in 2018 they
lost in the divisional round last year
against a packers team they probably
should have beaten and if they had a
better defense they probably would have
beaten right so um i it's just something
to keep an eye on chris yeah it's
something i'm very intrigued by a couple
of years out we've got a lot to worry
about between now and then let's just
not assume it's jamal adams and russell
wilson for the next seven or eight years
together in seattle it could be that it
becomes jamal adams team
uh within the next couple of well you
know to add to what you're saying here
too like i think one thing you know
i'm not even sure seattle really
understands how to play through russell
wilson yet is what i would argue maybe
they don't really know how to play that
way maybe that's why you know a pete
carroll and john schneider would want to
go back to that that old style what
you're talking about winning super bowls
through their defense and a running game
you know yeah the last two years we've
kind of let's let's go back you just
said it wild card lost divisional
playoff loss after both losses we've
gone what the hell why can't they give
the ball to russell wilson why can't
they throw the ball more why are they
wasting the ball like running the ball
like eight out of ten plays every set of
ten plays through the first three
quarters of the game and those big
moments so to me i would challenge you
i'm not even sure seattle knows how to
play through a quarterback quite yet you
know we talked about this i think it was
last week or maybe the week before to
where you know when we talked about
russell wilson you know they got to do
him justice and let just give him the
ball and go here and open it all up more
and uh so that that'll be interesting
you know and i also hear mike let me ask
you this question first off
all right there's there's there's two
things that jump i'll go one at a time
here two years from now we could still
have an affected salary cap right from
the pandemic right
so yep it's 175 next year for the 2021
season and then 2022 could also have you
know a chunk taken out of it even in
that year it would be 26 million dollars
of dead cap for russell wilson you know
if you're going 175 million again let's
just say in 2022 man i'd have a hard
time this is where this is a game
changer this year i'd have a hard time
thinking you could get rid of one
seventh
of your salary cap there and just let it
sit on the side in a year like that
which could affect teams and what
they're trying to do here you know in
the future as far as building their team
or their ultimate vision to what your
point might be here
the the other uh thing to keep in mind
and i think this is relevant as it
relates to
the seahawks
pete carroll
right at what point right at what point
and i'm not saying that they should move
on from pete carroll
but my my point is this if russell
wilson
is not satisfied with how he's used in
the offense you either get an offensive
coordinator who's going to use him the
right way or you get a coach that's
going to use him the right way if if
ultimately the choice is
you know not just not jamal adams versus
russell wilson but wilson versus
coaching staff yeah offensive
coordinator philosophy is that is that
where the is that where the pressure
point
really is residing and that if they you
know hey and pete carroll i mean look
the guy could coach another 10 15 years
if he wants to he's in great shape he's
got energy he's got positivity he's got
optimism best gum chewer in the game
right if they haven't figured out how to
use russell wilson by now
nine years in
chances are they're not going to have
some sort of an epiphany any time soon
it could be that carol either has to go
out and hire a coordinator who
specifically will have a plan for
getting the most out of wilson of course
if it works that guy will only be there
for one year then end up being hired as
a head coach somewhere else or they got
to get a head coach who's an offensive
guy carol's a defensive guy yeah maybe
they and again i'm not saying i i think
it would be a hell of a risk because i
would not let pete carroll walk away if
i'm the seahawks but if your impasse
ultimately is the head coach doesn't use
the quarterback the way the quarterback
should be used or wants to be used and
one or the other's got to go you have to
at least if you're the owner of the team
you have to at least
think through
both possibilities yeah what happens if
we get an offensive minded head coach
who would get the most out of russell
wilson and he stays here for the next 10
years or what if we just say we'll get a
new quarterback and we'll save a hell of
a lot of money because
russell wilson's gonna want
what
45 million or more per year when it's
time for his next contract yeah right no
they're all good questions they really
are and
you know
i mean i think your point that that
stuck out to me there more than anything
is like kind of what you said with a
pete carroll like well listen just daryl
bevel
and
and brian schottenheimer our defensive
coordinator head coach type of hires for
an offensive coordinator did that make
sense i hope it did i tried to say that
right but those those aren't like you
know those are offensive coordinators
that fit like oh i'm a defensive head
coach and this is how i want to play i
want to run the ball control the clock
and and play through my defense that's
how they are you're right you know if
they want to go the russell wilson route
and really go all in you'd have to get
you know
that next kyle shanahan type or sean
mcvay type to go to the next level to
push the bar on the offense and bring
some things in that you know like i i've
always said before like you know there's
certain things in in football russell
wilson doesn't even realize you know he
doesn't know what he doesn't even know
he's probably looking at plays that
brady and brees are running sometimes
and just going i don't get it like how's
that guy always open what are they doing
and i want to just go like sorry russell
yeah you don't have that play in your
playbook it's it stinks but you don't
got it and they don't coach it the right
way even when you guys do run it so uh
it'll be interesting to watch it all
nonetheless and hey mike last thing here
i don't know why but just with jamal
adams being signed and a few of the
other moves that seattle made this
weekend
does it is it you is it me or do i just
feel like it's like gideon clowney is
just inevitable to happen back in
seattle again i just feel like it's
going that way another one-year deal
i well i i don't think so chris i think
it makes it less likely they're going to
bring him back because whatever cap
space they have they're going to want to
bank it for jamal adams right um and and
he's not going to want whatever they
offer i mean they could have done that
that
tender that the giants did with marcus
golden that lapsed and now golden is
going to stay with the giants uh and it
would have been 15 million dollars
for genevieve and clowney and the the
seahawks didn't want to do it so
um you know it was it it was i may have
the number wrong but there was a floor
as to maybe it was 16 and a half million
but but whatever it was they didn't want
to put that out there
and i i think that it makes it clear
that whoever ends up signing genevieve
and clowny it's not going to be the
seahawks because they've already decided
not to put the kind of money out there
close to what he's looking for
but but hey the deal from friday changes
everything for everyone when we're
looking at a reduced cap in 2021 the
thing to remember is every additional
cap dollar you spend this year is one
fewer cap dollar you can carry over to
next year and the teams that are gonna
manage their way out of a mess next year
aren't gonna if they got 10 million left
this year don't spend another dime
save it and then you're looking at 185
next year so i think it makes it harder
for clowney and maybe hey maybe if
there's nothing else chris and the guy
just wants to play so i'm i guess i'm
gonna after two minutes agree with you
maybe if he has no other options that's
where i just feel like staying in the
place where he's been yeah if there
isn't the titans or the cowboys right
somebody else comes up with something
right
no yeah that's what that's what i'm
saying i just feel like you know yeah it
doesn't seem like a long-term deal is
going to get down
it seems like he's going to end up
signing a one-year deal i know it's
still early we don't know what's going
on but he also had great success that
there last year and it does seem like he
liked playing there and fit in the
environment and all that yeah i'm just
i'm just saying i just it seemed like it
felt like more of a possibility but
we'll see
i'm going to call an audible here on our
next topic because i see that espn is
reporting that the miami marlins now
have eight additional players who have
tested positive on top of the four who
had tested positive as of yesterday this
is a full-blown outbreak of covet 19 for
the miami marlins and this is baseball
folks they are not on top of each other
for three hours out on the field this is
the first major test for major league
sports as to how they're going to deal
with an outbreak of covet 19. uh it's
not good for sports it's not good for
baseball it's not good for the miami
marlins we're going to see how they work
it out but i wanted to mention that
chris because this definitely has
ramifications the miami team
in one of the worst hot spots in the
world right now in south florida oh and
the dolphins report tomorrow right um so
this optim that that's the thing what
we're going to have this year is it's
roller coaster we're going to feel good
about it one day and then something's
going to happen is going to make us
concerned and the question is does the
train ultimately stay on the tracks or
does it go off at some point and this
miami marlins thing has to at least put
on our radar screen the possibility that
uh
that there is gonna be an outbreak that
is gonna shut the nfl down or shut teams
down for one or two weeks at a time yeah
i mean it's a very real possibility but
you know it's another glaring example of
why we just got to get things
you know in our country under control
you know forget about sports anything
else anything in business is not going
to go working the right way right now oh
really oh really the team in south
florida where it's the hot spot of the
world right now they got an outbreak i'm
i'm shocked i'm shocked you know the you
know i mean just i don't know i mean so
yeah this is a societal issue that again
is going to filter into an em you know
uh american politics economics and all
those things and until we
do this right there's no fans in the
stadium there's no people working you
know at you know the the the different
stores in the stadium selling food the
vendors all that and it all affects the
economy because we don't want to you
know wear a mask when we walk down the
street because it doesn't go good with
our outfit or it's our freedom or like
i'm just you know okay it's our freedom
i'd like to have our freedom back and
the way to get the freedom back is to
start wearing the mask and doing the
things that help the society so what are
we gonna do just act like it doesn't
happen and just let society be ruined
you know at some point come on it's just
driving me crazy
yeah i mean if this all falls apart as
it relates to pro sports this isn't
because pro sports couldn't pull it off
it's because we couldn't pull it off as
a people because we were too stupid and
selfish to do what needed to be done and
now that we're waking up to it it's a
little bit too late and the other thing
i'd like to say is this folks and this
is a general observation that i make
based upon the fact that i leave my
house about once a week to go to the
store i just just to get out and just to
kind of see what's happening out in the
world in west virginia now masks are
mandatory but i can't tell you chris the
number of people
who wear a mask that does not cover
their nose
or
or think it's okay
to take a break from the mask and pull
it down under their chin like they're
lifting weights and this is just the set
break until they get back on the bench
it's like the mask is mandatory you
cover your nose with it and it's amazing
to me that these stores will let people
in that they don't say anything to them
when they do it everyone's afraid to say
anything because no matter who's going
to pull out an ak-47
uh it's just craziness wear the mask and
wear it right or stay home it's that
simple rant over yeah uh you don't don't
even get me started okay i mean yes
you're right i don't get it
you know we got to take the proper
precautions yes air droplets come out of
your nose all you scientists out there
so cover your damn nose and if you want
to pull your mask down and get a
breather
don't be within 20 feet of anybody be
outside in an area where you're away
from anybody don't make other people
feel uncomfortable so
yeah i don't know there's so many issues
there right now it just don't i can't
even get started i'll get us fired let's
just go on to the next subject this is
the ultimate character test for the
people who give a crap about others and
those who don't and those who are
willing to walk around
with essentially a middle finger
to the rest of the world and there are
people like that everywhere and i
definitely encounter them here and of
course uh you know i i think about
should i say something should i do
something but it's like you know i don't
want to get stabbed i don't want to get
shot and i don't want some incident that
ends up on youtube that i'm the star of
so i just get my stuff and i get the
hell out and i stay away from the person
who's not wearing the mask the right way
or not wearing a mask at all all right
last topic before we end this edition of
pftot as it relates to the potential of
outbreaks in the nfl peter king in
football morning in america raises a
possibility and i think isn't just
speculation i think he knows something
we do that sometimes in this business we
know things that we can't say that we
know but we try to get ahead of where
the ball is moving because we know it's
true but we can't report it
the possibility that the commissioner
will have the discretion to postpone
individual games based upon the covet 19
situation for a given team
now with a team like the miami marlins
it's a no-brainer right chris if you
can't field 46 healthy players because
of injuries because of covet 19 if you
just don't have the bodies then you
shouldn't be expected to play the idea
though and peter mentions this what if
the vikings starting offensive line is
all positive for the virus
would the commissioner postpone a week
seven game against whoever they're
supposed to play that week because they
don't want the vikings to have their
backup offensive line protecting kirk
cousins see i don't think that's good
enough i at the nfl i don't need
ultimate next man it's next man up right
as long as you have 46 healthy players
who can suit up and play you play if you
get to a point where there's enough of
an outbreak where come sunday morning or
monday night or thursday night you just
physically can't
put 46 guys on the field or on the
sidelines obviously not on the field
that would be a penalty uh you you you
that's when it would happen but anything
less than that yeah i don't want to hear
it you're if you're if if you don't have
good enough backup alignment then put
your backup quarterback on the field if
you don't trust your backup lineman to
protect your starting quarterback and
that's just the way it goes we never
make those accommodations for injury the
eagles last year had i mean they would
have loved to postpone a few of those
yeah right when it was carson wentz and
a bunch of no-name slappys around him
all due respect to those guys
we just don't do that in football so i
don't like it other than in a situation
where a team would not be able to put 46
players in uniform yeah right i don't
want to like if it's like just the two
starting guards and we're going to
cancel a game because we're like oh
we don't we don't we don't think we can
take take it a step farther what if it's
the entire offensive line well if it's
the intensive life if it's the entire
offensive line and you legitimately
can't feel like a starting five
okay then of course that's where i go
yeah there's an you got to do something
here but if you're like
you know
okay if it's four out of five and you
got you know seven backup offensive
linemen who have been on the practice
squad they're ready to go or anything
like that
yeah i don't want to see a a week
canceled because of that or just because
like oh we don't want tom brady or aaron
rodgers to get hurt this week like
that's not a reason you cancel games if
you literally can't play the game that's
one thing and then to me like what what
i don't understand here mike is
are they saying like
you'll cancel the vikings bear game in
week seven but the rest of football will
play that week so then we're gonna have
uneven schedules like how does a
tiebreaker work like that to me is where
i just don't understand it okay
what would happen is
potentially the game that gets canceled
week seven gets played week 18 and if
there's a game that gets cancelled week
10 it gets played week 18. i mean as
long as none of those games involve the
same team you can pull it off right or
you can have a couple of weeks on the
back end you know this is instead of
wiping out a full week there's been talk
about for example they could take it
take week three and put it at the end of
the season they could take week four and
put it at the end of the season if they
need to week two every game played in
week two is between teams that have
their buys the same week you could get
rid of week two and just play all those
games in the weeks those teams otherwise
would be on a buy this is individual
games in a given week this team can't
play postpone this game play at week 18
or week 19. okay that's what it would be
i just i still don't like
yeah i think anything other than 46 guys
aren't available
you made your bet you got to make your
decisions about who's on your roster you
got to make your decisions about who's
on your practice squad you got to have
enough guys available and you know what
you may have to have a defensive lineman
play offensive line this game you may
have to do it you may have to have a
safety play receiver this game you may
have to do it that happens in football
and um i i think that it makes much more
sense to go forward with the games and
get the games in and start postponing
games having a slippery slope of a
standard and potentially getting to the
point where you suggested chris where
you just can't get the games in so
you've got some teams that have played
15 some play 16 some play 14 some maybe
play as few as 13 and you're determining
playoff positioning based on winning
percentage i don't like it at all no no
you're right it's uh it's gonna be
something to watch out for
you know i guess the big thing is is
where do you
you know yeah like you're talking about
just where do you draw the line
yeah i want to if you can get 46 out
there i want to see you play but you
know at the same time
if it's you can get 46 out there but
you know mike you got to play like three
defensive linemen on the offensive side
of the ball
and they've only pl they've only they
were only made aware of this like friday
night so they're all of a sudden
saturday trying to figure this out i
don't know if that's fair i don't know
if that's fair for players player safety
all of those type of things so i got to
wrap my head around that a little bit
more i certainly want teams to exhaust
all avenues to try to play like you're
saying because i think it's going to
confuse things and and who knows what
else the other repercussions are but i
also think there is a fine line of like
okay let's let's not just field 46 and
then have like you know 15 guys get hurt
because we just got like you know our
kicker playing right tackle this week
against von miller and all of a sudden
our quarterback's dead too let alone our
kicker's dead from bond miller running
them over all the time
well we'll see how it all plays out i
mean we we are accepting the reality
that this year is not going to have much
competitive balance there will be
unfairness some teams will have fans
present some teams won't
i just think if we start going down this
path of giving the commissioner the
discretion to postpone individual games
and you don't have a hard standard as to
what would postpone a game you're really
asking for trouble because there could
be
a strong perception of unfairness that
one team that is up against it has to
play and another team doesn't and gets
to play that game later that's a
dangerous move for the nfl to make and
let's hope it doesn't get to that all
right uh that's it we're done we'll be
back tuesday with another edition of pft
live everybody have a great day check us
out all day long at profootballtalk.com
and we'll see you tomorrow peace
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports